Andrea is with us in Omaha Nebraska hi
Andrea how are you hi Mr Ramsey it's a
pleasure to speak with you you too
what's up I've been listening to you for
about six months and it just gives me
hope for the future and I really
appreciate it well anytime how can I
help
today um I am 33 I'm about
$62,000 in credit card debt um I had a
house fire and I was on disability for
my job for a couple of years and I was
only working part-time I kept telling
myself as I was doing it I was like oh
I'll make more money next year I'll be
able to pay this all off well I met the
situation I met now and I for the last
year I've been making enough money
between my two jobs to make minimum
payments and then pay a little bit so I
actually was higher than this in debt
and I paid a little bit down but um I've
been told that my primary job that pays
about ,000 a week that I'm probably uh
looking at losing that in 30 days so
there's going to probably be a period of
time maybe two to three months where
even between working you know another 40
hour week job which I would start you
know as soon as this one ends and
another one I'm not going to be making
enough money to even make um my minimum
payments plus pay you know for housing
and all the other necessary things so
I'm just wondering uh getting into that
situation which I've never not been able
to make my minimum payment before like
what's the best thing to do to you know
minimize the impact uh on you know my
credit you know obviously and uh you
know not causing as many more problems
than necessary in my
finances well your credit is um one of
our last
concerns um it's a concern but it's not
it's not real high on the priority list
uh the primary thing on the priority
list is you take care of Necessities or
Essentials and so the the first thing
you buy with money in this crisis
situation is
food
period the second thing you buy is
utilities lights and
water the third thing you do is you pay
your house payment how much is your
house
payment uh 550 a month very manageable
good and so I mean if you have lights
and water food and a place to
stay you can live to another
day because it changes your emotions if
you 100% know that those things are done
and you can do all of that out of your
current part-time
job yes that's correct okay so what I'm
doing here is is what happens in our
mind is you they come in and say oh
layoffs are coming and all of us have a
drama queen that lives inside of us that
goes
bananas when we hear that and so it's
good to kind of walk back through the
logic and go well I'm going to be a
bleed
I'll be able to keep the lights and
water on I'm going to keep the house
payment pay before I do anything else
now do you owe anything on your
car no I own my car outright good good
so we're gonna keep gas and insurance on
the car that's the next thing and we'll
buy basic necessity clothing but nothing
else now that's food shelter clothing
transportation and utilities it's what
we call the four walls of your house
which means that you you've got the four
walls up you've got a Shield up between
you and life everything else is a
Monopoly game that you're not winning
right
now no I mean I've been scrambling just
to you know make my minimum payments and
it's you know just finally coming up to
bite me yeah so what I'm saying is
though that's the Monopoly game the
credit score the payments on credit
cards that kind of stuff no one's going
to come take your house or keep you from
eating because of those things now do we
want to pay them sure do we want to pay
them as quickly as we can sure do we
want to completely eliminate the debt
sure but those are wants not needs a and
um so that's our first goal now do you
have anything other than credit card
debt no everything that I owe is on
credit cards okay then uh let's what I
would do is pay the payments on the
smallest
ones first because it's the smallest
payments until the money Runs Out so
that's going to leave only your big ones
that go unpaid they're fewer in number
which lowers the hassle factor of the
number of collectors calling you and
they're fewer in number which lowers the
dings to your credit bureau report the
weird thing is you get the same ding on
your credit bureau being laate on a
$1,000 credit card balance as being laid
on a $10,000 credit card
balance okay that makes sense and so
let's knock off all the little ones
first as many as we can and until the
money runs out now what do you do for a
living on your main day
job um I drive uh sem my
truck okay that's great
news because you ought to be able to
land another gig well I mean yeah I was
looking at it and um you know other jobs
in the area that would start out that
you know like could immediately pick up
would pay about 600 um about 600 um uh a
week so like I I F it's like a $1,200 a
month pay cut it's like a $115,000 year
pay
cut uh yes so I mean you know it's like
I would be are you single on being able
yes I am
kids
no have you thought about as a temporary
measure going over the road and getting
your income way
up um I mean really like uh my my
part-time job is at up yes and I've been
there for like 12 years and I'm making
really good money there plus my benefits
what's what's really good
money $2 an hour okay you are that's
good yeah and you would lose that and so
you probably you probably wouldn't break
even then you're right okay I agree with
you you know there's the whole part
about being out you know I mean there's
something to be said for being able to
sleep in your own bed I oh there's
definitely something to be said for that
but I was going to say temporarily
there's something to be said with to to
give up that to uh be rid of $62,000
because there's something to be said for
that too but I think I don't think you I
don't think you make money by going on
the road I think you're right with your
UPS fabulous second job you don't you
don't gain anything I'm wrong you're
you're right I agree I've been I've been
looking you know back and forth and
adding up all the hours I'd be working
and pretty much like yeah you know if I
just started out to 600 I mean it would
probably only be like a three to four
months situation because I am like doing
things to like increase my pay I can get
as a truck driver like I'm applying to
get my Howard materials endorsement
which increases like how much you can
make per hour by or definitely I mean I
think it's just G to be like a temporary
situation like maybe three to four
months so your advice then would be to
just yeah just to let the big one slide
if something has to slide if you can't
cut the budget down far enough to make
something work but um it also sounds to
me like you're making probably 70 or
$80,000 a year and I'm wondering if you
can't cut your overall budget down you
don't have much housing expense you
don't have car expense um I'm going to
really work to cut this budget down to
nothing and see if I can't lean into
this 62,000 a lot
harder I'd like for that be completely
gone within two years this is the day
Ramy
show